Dishonored 2 looks like it's going to
have a star-studded voice cast just like
the first game I'm Kate and this is your
steampunk stealth news update with names
such as Susan Sarandon Lena Headey
Michael Madsen Carrie Fisher and John
Slattery in the credits of the first
dishonored game the sequel has a lot to
live up to but it looks like they might
already be reeling in the big fish after
developer Arkane Studios shared part of
the new cast with Game Informer Vincent
D'Onofrio and rosario Dawson who play
Wilson Fisk and Claire temple in
daredevil have been confirmed as the
Duke of circa nose and the dreadful
whale captain Pedro Pascal who played
the eye catching over in Martell and
Game of Thrones is down to play Paulo
the howler gang leader it was also
revealed that previously silent
protagonist corvo attano will be voiced
by steven Russell who's best known as
the voice of thief's garrett and fallout
4s Nick Valentine fallout 4 voice actor
Erica lateral place Emily cold wind
asana to second protagonist the cast
members includes Sam Rockwell seen in
films such as moon and Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy Robin Lord Taylor
from Gotham and Jamie Hector from the
wire Dishonored 2 is set for a November
11th release on ps4 xbox one and pc
bethesda is expected to reveal the first
gameplay at its e3 event in June are you
impressed with the casting sofa or are
you going to rein in your excitement
until you see the first preview let me
know in the comments or come and find me
on Twitter I'm at how not to draw thanks
for watching and for all your gaming and
entertainment news keep it gamespot